la ciudad jordana de ácava en el mar
rojo recibe la primera reunión en una
década entre funcionarios palestinos e
israelíes con la mediación de las
autoridades jordanas de Egipto y de
Estados Unidos un encuentro de este tipo
No ocurría desde 2012 cuando Israel y la
autoridad Palestina mantuvieron
conversaciones también en Jordania con
representantes de Estados Unidos Rusia
la Unión Europea y la ONU en Sí esta
Cumbre se plantea objetivos de seguridad
de ahí la asistencia de los jefes de los
servicios de inteligencia con la misión
de calmar la violencia que sólo en dos
meses de 2023 se traduce en la muerte de
al menos 62 palestinos en sijordania por
fuego israelí y once israelíes en dos
ataques palestinos en Jerusalén este
aunque reina el escepticismo sobre los
compromisos que se pueden alcanzar y
sobre todo sobre su posterior
cumplimiento Israel podría ofrecer una
reducción de las redadas en sijordania y
un freno temporal a la expansión de
asentamientos demoliciones y desalojos
de palestinos mientras que la autoridad
Palestina estaría dispuesta a paralizar
las iniciativas críticas de Israel en la
ONU y otros foros internacionales
también según varios analistas el
gobierno de majuda Baz buscaba Mostrar
que tiene un futuro político frente a su
falta de legitimidad entre la población
Palestina y de hecho por esta Cumbre ya
ha recibido un fuerte rechazo de los
grupos armados locales entre ellos están
jamás el grupo islamista que gobierna en
gaza las brigadas de los mártires del
Axa que es el brazo armado del partido
fatal de magma islámica Palestina el
consenso entre ellos es que estos
encuentros se legitiman las acciones
israelíes en los territorios ocupados y
no traen soluciones reales para los
palestinos